there's a cliche question here
but let's try to actually get
to some deep truth perhaps
but people who don't know much about
chess seem to like to use chess as a
metaphor for everything in life
but there is some aspect to the
decision-making
to the kind of reasoning and involved in
chess that's transferable to other
things
can you can you speak to that in your in
your own life and in general
the kind of reasoning involved with
chess
how much does that does transfer to
life out there it just helps to make
decisions i mean of all of all kinds
yeah that would be my main takeaway that
you learn to make informed guesses in a
limited amount of time
i mean does it frustrate you when you
know that you have
geopolitical thinkers and leaders you
know henry kissinger will often talk
about geopolitics as a game of chess or
3d chess
is that a too oversimplified of a
projection or
or do you think that the kind of
deliberations you have on the world
stage is
is similar to the kind of decision
making you have on the chessboard
well i never i'm never trying to get
reelected when i play a game of chess
there's no special interest you have to
get happy yeah that kind of works no
that kind of helps no i can i can
understand
that obviously for every action there's
a reaction and you have to to calculate
far ahead it probably would be a good
thing if more
big players on the international scene
thought a little bit more like
like a chess player in that sense like
trying to make
a good decision based on um
based on limited amount of data rather
than thinking about other
other factors but it's so tough uh but
it does annoy me when
when people make moves that they know
are wrong for different reasons and they
should know if they did some calculation
they should know they're wrong yeah
exactly that they should know that are
wrong and
so much
politics is like
it's um
you're you're often asked to do
something when you're
when it would be much better to do
nothing uh
like
no but that happens in chess all the
time like you have you have a choice
like i often tell people that
in certain situations you should not try
and win you should just let your
opponent loose
and
that happens in politics all the time
yeah just let your opponents
continue whatever they're doing and then
you'll win don't try to do something
just to do something often
they say in chess that having a bad plan
is better than having no plan it's
absolute nonsense
i forget what general said it but uh it
was like uh don't interrupt your enemy
when they're making a mistake
yeah i think
also um
patrocian um
the the former world champion said um
when your opponent wants to play dutch
defense don't stop them
i mean chess players will know that it's
the same thing
you